expedition unknown hunt for
extraterrestrials premieres tonight at
9:00 Eastern Time 8:00 central on the
Travel Channel and the man who is the
host of that program the very popular
Josh gates here on the Rich Eisen show
good to see you Josh great to see you
man let's unpack our story first shall
we
it was 15 years ago it was 2002 yeah I
met you in Times Square in New York City
for the very first time that's right and
I last saw you
on the roof of Alcatraz that was the
last on the roof of an abandoned
cellblock on Alcatraz Island and there's
the photograph of it Yahoo and the rest
of the winners of beg borrow and deal
the ESPN I believe to reality show I
don't know if it was on the biggie I
don't remember it was thick their first
big foray into doing a big reality
competition show let's be honest it was
our big first four yeah it was the
highlight of our careers I think we can
agree and the worldwide leaders all
together yes and the photograph of me
with the rest of the winners you and the
the trio of your compatriots yeah two
teams of four that had no money no
identification we took away your wallets
in your cash in Times Square
yes sent you on some goose chase across
the country first to complete a bunch of
sports challenge yeah the idea was there
was a list of 50 sports related tasks
and whichever team could complete ten of
them and make it to Alcatraz Island
first first would win the show and I was
the host of it so yes I remember it was
like okay we're gonna start it on
such-and-such a day come on down from
Bristol yeah so I did my stand-ups to
use the television term yeah then I met
you and Kelly Zink who wound up being a
production assistant yeah on the NFL
Network she helped launch the NFL
Network years later that's right and
Juliet who's I believe a real housewife
of London now she's on ladies of London
yeah it's you're a hit maker I was Brock
when I was flying on a plane I'm like
this girl looks awfully familiar on
Bravo right now she's on beg borrow and
deal part of Josh gates yeah going
across the country yeah and some like
Clemson Tiger fan named Bubba that's
right
this is a true story and then I got a
phone call one day on SportsCenter
saying okay I know you're on
SportsCenter tomorrow night but this
group of people are gonna make it to
Alcatraz tomorrow you got to get on a
flight right now and get to San
Francisco for tomorrow Mike really right
boom I dropped everything and flew all
the way out and stood on the roof of
Alcatraz and then you stroll down you
know actually we were we were in this
cellblock yeah and then you stroll
around the corner and I smelled you
before I heard you had not showered in
like a month that's right that's right
we we had been I forget how long it took
us to get it done but yeah we we
completed ten of the tasks and made it
to Alcatraz it was a crazy experience
now I mean like because one of them was
you you caught a pass from Jesse Palmer
right because you had to go into the
Giants facility and catch a pass from a
real NFL quarterback yeah that like the
tasks were hard right it was like sing
the national anthem at a major league
baseball game yes no no big deal catch a
catch a pass beat beat a NBA player to
game a horse I mean they were like
pretty like legit difficult things to
pull off I mean luckily you could stroll
in anywhere and say we're doing a show
with ESPN that helped write that
definitely but really we were kind of on
our own to go figure these things out
did you throw out a first pitch at a
minor league baseball game yeah I think
I think we let Juliet throw out the
first pitch no it was that talked your
way into this you did talk yeah exactly
she threw the first pitch I think it was
in a White Sox game
she's like impossible but maybe and then
again winding up on Alcatraz first you
wound up winning the grand prize which
was if which was a pack of gum no and a
bus ticket home no no break you know it
was for the Super Bowl the Kentucky
Derby it was it was four pairs of
tickets yeah to any four championship
sporting events in the u.s. within a
calendar year did you go in yeah I mean
I'm not a sports guy at least I was on
the show is that I'm like a big guy who
seems like you should know something
about sports and I don't Josh gates of
expedition unknown here but you should
know they did tell me the producers
before I met you okay now one of the
guys on the team right knows nothing
about that's go easy on him right he's
what he basically told me beforehand so
which could which ones did you write
like this is a prize for a sports fan
that would be outrageous right I was
looking at it based on because I'm a
travel nut so I'm like well where can I
go with these so a lot of guys would
have chosen the Super Bowl I was living
in LA Super Bowl was in San Diego to me
no interest in that okay so I went to
the Pro Bowl in Hawaii yeah because I
wanted to go to Hawaii with my
girlfriend good for you
right yeah not the best game in the
world but yeah it was a free trip to
hawaii-i-i wanted to go to the Iditarod
and they were like no dude we're know
that doesn't count I was like that's a
championship
sporting event you've been to the
Iditarod never been but I lived in
Alaska for two different times for seven
years total so I know all about the idea
Terrell they literally were like now
let's pick something else I did the
World Series I was hoping it was gonna
be the Red Sox which wasn't until year
later so it was yeah it was New York
Florida and Yankee Stadium and also you
got to watch the Marlins beat the
Yankees yeah just a rich man yeah that's
as close to seeing the red song exactly
right and then Final Four New Orleans
basketball and then and then I let my
mom pick one I said mom whatever you
want to go do and what you and I thought
she was gonna choose the US Open she
chose Kentucky Derby so we went down to
the Kentucky Derby and she picked the
winning horse we won 500 bucks so you
know it was it was awesome and you
thought you didn't win money being on
Barrow and deal yeah and now look at you
man you are you have built a career out
of this sort of out of not showering
well no no out of out of just throwing
caution to the wind and live in life and
trying to crack codes that you don't
know that could be cracked yeah it's
been a it's been a really amazing
journey since that show actually and and
and funny enough that the producer who
who made beg borrow and deal the manse
the manse and they sold this concept for
the next show that I did to sci-fi they
needed a host they need to travel guys
so really without beg borrow and deal I
would never have come to that
opportunity which would never have led
me to Travel Channel so I guess what I'm
saying is I owe it all to you is that
know what what we're saying but Josh
gates host of the Travel Channel
expedition unknown hunt for
extraterrestrials that if you one day do
in fact prove that we are not the only
piece
in this world or galaxy or what-have-you
it all starts with that Schmo a sho beg
borrow away that's right it really does
it all started there that'll be on my
epitaph we are not alone that's right
essentially ya know it's a this this
special is really cool kicks off tonight
I'm really excited about it it's it's
you know it's a question that everybody
has asked you know who who hasn't sort
of looked up at the stars at some point
and said what else is out there so this
was a chance to go literally around the
world we did about 50,000 miles four
continents to investigate this question
of life in the universe
from NASA's Mission Control all the way
down to you know experiencers who claim
they've you know been abducted hmm
everywhere in between so can you tell me
what what is the closest that you came
away saying all right I believe it I
believe it I know we are not the only
ones on the science side I walked away
fully believing that there's life in the
universe you know talking to some of the
world's best astronomers astronaut
scientists they're convinced now there's
a real consensus that that they're
finding these earth-like planets at a
pretty alarming rate so you know I think
now it would be weird if there wasn't
life in the universe earth is not as
unique I think as we thought it was
maybe 10 20 years ago mm-hmm so from
that side of things I'm all in I mean it
just seems like there has to be the
conditions for life are out there so
there has to be this other question of
like are they like here and skulking
around in the shadows and abducting
people and probing them that's that's a
much more difficult guy well I don't
think you've ever met Mike Dell Tufo
over there our sound audio engineer
there sometimes where I feel like he's
an alien life-form sometimes it's the
way he pod person
maybe nod but not like not like men in
black where it's the Delta fo suit all
right or zipped up I'm a little plugged
I'm the plug in men in black you know
yeah how many people have you met that
believe this because it's the only way
they can explain what's happening I
think that's part of it I mean we are
really in like in pop culture and
entertainment and literature yes we love
aliens I mean they're it's a big part of
movie industry you know we love these
stories so I think every time somebody
sees a weird light in the sky a lot of
folks just flash straight to must be a
UFO I was driving to in regarding day
morning
this very Sunday 4:00 in the morning
coming off the 405 and there was a big
flash of bright blue light that lit up
the sky three different times and I
flipped out and what do you think it was
I have no earthly idea it's about it's
near LAX
I don't know what it was all right I was
thinking maybe you can help me with that
maybe you know you're losing sleep are
you feeling leave but I'm just did you
hear anything about sunrise or am i you
were close to an airport so we have some
possible options here there was no
weather balloon right well but no look
we met people on this on this special
who had stories that you know completely
blow me away there's a guy named Travis
Walton whose story was made into a film
called fire in the sky there was also a
book Travis is a guy that we met with
that I've known this guy was a a logger
in Arizona up in the mountains with six
other guys logging knocked off at the
end of the day headed home in a pickup
truck in the in the in the woods they
see a bright light Travis gets out of
the truck these other six guys stay in
the truck there screaming Travis don't
get out don't get out they see him get
blown off his feet by this light he
vanishes you can go on Wikipedia skies
stories incredible the six guys go back
to town the police assume that they've
murdered this guy I mean they're coming
back to town saying oh this this buddy
of ours vanished you know they all
passed lie-detector tests a few days
later Travis Walton re-emerges in town
emaciated confused come on it's one of
those stories were and these are like
these are like blue-collar forestry
workers and you hear this guy's story
and he has this I mean on paper crazy
story he was abducted he went up into
the spaceship and you hear and you go
that's impossible we're coming up on the
40th anniversary of Close Encounters
yeah hitting the movie theaters it's
that this very month yeah 40 years which
also seems crazy I know but you know
these you people have these stories that
are not easy to explain doesn't mean
that aliens abducted them but I met all
sorts of folks that left me at the end
of their interviews feeling like I don't
know how to explain this away Travel
Channel's expedition unknown hunt for
extraterrestrials premieres tonight at
9:00 Eastern Time how many miles do you
have in your frequent-flyer account you
know a gentleman never
discuss this it's not like a golf
handicap word what do you mean a lot
gentlemen never a lot you've traveled
the world you're on the travel child I
know a lot nice I mean millions million
so you could basically not pay for well
you can you definitely pay no worth much
anymore right like like I flew my I'm
flying my parents out here for Christmas
yeah
and it was like to get them from the
Boston out here and back is like like
almost half a million I mean it's like
an insane number of miles to get to get
flights a true you were on a corner of
the earth and found out you were having
a kid yeah I was in I was in Haiti we
were filming an episode on Christopher
Columbus in in Haiti and we have a sort
of like you know emergency Sat phone
yeah it doesn't ring very often yeah and
it rang and we were filming and on air
you know I found out that I was my
wife's having a baby so it was a great
kind of emotional moment oh nice yeah
now I left it in the show you know you
you your wife is cool with I don't want
to mix anything yeah no no that's not
the reality show no she's she's very
cautious about uh our kid is not on
social media you know but but but this
was such a cool kind of real moment that
we put it on all I know is that my
middle kid it was close to him being
born and it was the Super Bowl about two
and a half weeks beforehand and it was a
little dicey especially when the OB
asked for tickets to go to the game I
said don't ask me for tickets you go ask
my wife exactly exactly stir this game
exactly yeah man but congratulations
thank you yeah and we actually have
another one on the way so okay so are
you off now what you're off to another
spot I leave on I leave on Sunday to go
to Egypt for three weeks we're filming a
show there and then you know I mean the
this is definitely a be careful what you
wish for a job I mean you you travel all
the time too but I I do about do about
250 days a year abroad
usually in not-so-great places so it's
it's a big schedule where's the one
place you would never go back
stuff question uh Alcatraz the roof of
alka the roof of Alcatraz I can take it
all back the Giants practice bubble can
surpass you Jesse Palmer yeah exactly
there are places
there are places I feel like like
central age I'm not that big unlike that
the the stands the Kazakhstan's the
abacus Becca Stan I'm kind of I mean I
don't hate them but boy the food stuff
okay all right well congrats on
everything that's happened to you man I
cannot believe ESPN put the kibosh on
sending you to the Iditarod right what
in the world is that man I mean how much
cost an Alaska Airlines ticket they
don't even show it on the Ocho I guess
its way around
they don't good to see you Josh great
come anytime thanks man so thrilled in
let's let's not do it once every 15
years exactly let's go to Alcatraz more
off Travel Channel's expedition unknown
hunt for extraterrestrials premieres
tonight at 9:00 Eastern Time on Travel
Channel the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you like
that please download our app there's
lots of fun things there other than just
more of the videos you just saw you can
call us from the app you can email us
from the app just download it trust me
you'll enjoy